welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins sitting in for
David Pakman today I was also sitting in
for David Pakman yesterday when I talked
about the fact that Donald Trump is
laying the groundwork right now as he
was all weekend long to fire Jeff
Sessions now obviously this is something
that's gonna kind of stay in the news
for quite a while here there's gonna be
this will he or won't he with Jeff
Sessions and Donald Trump probably at
least until the midterms hit which is
when Republicans predict Donald Trump is
gonna go ahead and fire jeff Sessions
according to reports that came out
yesterday afternoon Donald Trump's
lawyers inside the White House claimed
that they are the ones who are
convincing Trump to not fire Jeff
Sessions ahead of the midterms however
there's always a caveat to everything
and this story is no exception you have
these Republican senators according to
the Washington Post who have already
resigned themselves to the fact that
Jeff Sessions is going to be gone as
soon as the voting stops in the midterms
I mean look we've got people Roy Blunt
richard shelby bob Corker just to name a
few that are listed here in this
Washington Post story about the issue
these are people who at one point we're
sticking up for Jeff Sessions they
weren't gonna stand by and let the
president bully him they were certainly
gonna raise hell if he decided to fire
him but now they're all saying like yeah
you know he's probably gonna be fired
and what we in do right they worked with
the man for years sometimes decades in
the US Senate these are his friends
and though I hate everything Jeff
Sessions has done and disagree with him
on everything he stands for and says he
has no friends left there is nobody in
DC that appears to have any kind of
loyalty towards him whatsoever and
that's kind of sad for Jeff especially
because he's going to end up being fired
for the one right thing he did during
his tenure as Attorney General and that
is to recuse himself from the rush
investigation he did so many other
horrible bad things for Donald Trump
made sure as Justice Department was
separating migrant families got rid of
asylum you know talking about how we've
got to get rid of all marijuana and
strengthen our marijuana laws and bring
back the war on drugs all of those were
horrible ideas and then he does one good
thing recuse himself and now he's gonna
get fired for it don't get me wrong I
think Jeff Sessions absolutely never
deserved to be Attorney General in the
first place I would love to see him gone
because he's a horrible person I also
understand the reality which is that
we're gonna get somebody just as bad if
not worse than Jeff Sessions and I also
understand why Trump wants to fire him
he wants to fire him so he can get to
Robert Muller put it into an attorney
general who's not going to recuse
themselves they're gonna take over the
investigation but even if that happens
that's not going to destroy the
investigation this is not a doomsday
scenario you know Nixon tried the same
thing when he fired the special
prosecutor investigating him forced to
replace him and ended up with a special
prosecutor who put the investigation on
steroids and finished it a lot quicker
than the other one forcing Nixon to
resign a little bit earlier so there's
no good outcome for this entire story
for Donald Trump
but the story here is not Trump and it's
not sessions the story is all of these
Republicans who spent years working side
by side with Jeff sessions there were
his friends and lunch together you know
they hung out after work they are too
scared to stand up to Donald Trump to
protect their friend that tells you
everything you need to know about the
current makeup of the Republican Party
here in the United States